hello everyone and welcome to the second
game of the match Magnus Crossing versus
Vaseline venchuk or Evancho versus
costan as evangelic has the white pieces
here from the video World Cup uh Magnus
won the first game and now uh eventually
needs to win the game in order to bounce
back and forth tie breaks so let's see
what happened here uh what did he choose
as his opening choice and was he able to
put any pressure on Magnus Carlsen uh
let's dive straight into it so E4 by uh
by Chucky we have Pawn to E5 Knight to
F3 Knight to C6 and Bishop to B5 uh the
real Lopez is on the board we have
pawned a six morphe's defense Bishop to
A4 and now Knight to F6 we have castles
and Bishop to E7 so very very standard
stuff here uh Rook to E1 we have Pawn to
B5 Bishop to B3 castles and pawn to A4
now again all been seen before the
anti-martial not
um not going for anything crazy uh we
have rooked the B8 this is a well not as
a played move as for example Bishop B7
which is the main move here also you can
play B4 also D for a D5 it has been
played uh Rook to B is a solid move but
uh somewhat rare with a captures a
captures and now Pawn to C3 preparing
Pawn to D4 Magnus plays D6 and now Pawn
to D4 E Capture C captures and now the
immediate Pawn to D5 also uh here are
some other ideas have been tried knife
to be for preparing C5 also just
developing the bishop the G4 is a very
nice but D5 by Magnus and now Pawn to E5
so why why did Magnus allow this
expansion in the center well Knight to
E4 it's just a beautiful piece here and
if um avastle develops with Knight to C3
Magnus will just trade remember Magnus
only needs a draw in this game to win
the match tonight the C3 Knight captures
B captures and now Bishop to F5 Magna
solves the problem of developing his
light Square bishop and uh there is a
game where Rook the A6 was played and it
does make sense to play such a move
going after the night as the Knight is
undefined ended on C6 instead we have
Pawn to H3 by vassal and it is now as of
move 16 that we have a completely new
game okay Magnus uh continues
development Queen to D7 now the Knight
is also protected so maybe Rook to A6
isn't all that impressive uh Bishop to
E3 just continuing development and now
while Magnus could go for something like
Rook to A8 trying to trade off a pair of
Rook seagulls for Knight to d8 this
prepares C5 and also prepares to bring
the Knight over to E6 that's okay Knight
to D2 and here we have Pawn to B4 the
immediate Pawn to B4 by Magnus now uh C5
also makes sense it's very hard to uh to
understand why Magnus would go for B4
first before playing C5 because you know
that C5 is the move you have to play and
it's sort of a force line D captures
Knight to the E6 of course and now you
want to re-maneuver the Knight also you
want to recapture on C5 so C6 Queen
captures Queen to F3 now putting
pressure on the D5 Pawn uh but just the
bishop to E4 so yeah it's not really not
really an issue Knight captures an E4
the counters Queen to G4 and now Knights
the C5 and now you are you have some
ideas for bringing the Knight to D3 also
the bishop here is hanging so Bishop
captures and C5 Bishop captures and now
Queen captures any for now it's okay to
grab the pawn queen captures Rook
captures and for example Now Pawn to B4
and everything gets traded off
um a very nice draw here so maybe Magnus
thought that this was uh maybe uh dude
well it's just not much to play for so
he plays B4 right away and uh of course
this invites uh vassal to play Pawn to
C4 which he does c c captures mb4 isn't
very ambitious especially if you want to
win the game so D captures and C for
Bishop captures and now Pawn to C6 uh
taking away the D5 Square from White's
pieces and also you cannot just start
advancing those pawns uh Queen to a for
now uh and here we have Rook the B7
Magnus just nicely the fence and also
stops Queen to A7 but one thing that
Evancho has going for him is that he is
much much better on the clock he has an
hour and 20 minutes on the clock where
his Magnus is already down to some 40
minutes on the clock so Knight to F1 he
wants to re-maneuver the Knight to G3
probably if he's not going to be able to
create some sort of an attack against
the black king he will have to resort to
some f for G4 F5 ideas and then just go
for an all-out attack uh Knight to E6
and now Knights the G3 with Bishop to G6
getting the bishop out of Harm's Way so
you're not in time to capture the D4
pawn and now let's just defends it with
the Rook eat D1 and okay both players
that played fairly quickly while still
down to an hour and 10 minutes Magnus
still has some 40 minutes on the clock
uh Knight to C7 the night coming to an
even better Square the D5 square and now
Queen back to B3 uh Knight to D5 uh this
also doesn't just put the Knight on a
brilliant square like this but it also
stops spawn to E6 as this could be
somewhat of an issue here uh Rook to A5
and now we have Rook the A7 and here
where uh when Evancho saw this rooked A7
move he was very unhappy uh because uh
it it almost looked like he missed this
move it means that it's just gonna be
way too easy for Magnus to trade down
material and there just will not be uh
hold that a lot to play for so Rook
detail A1 uh Rook after A8 and now we
have a trade Rook captures real captures
with Rook captures and queen captures
The Rook uh all of the Rooks get traded
off the board and now Knight the E2 it
would be a bit too dangerous maybe to
capture on the five captors captures and
queen captures uh as uh okay you've
grabbed the pawn but maybe now the B4
Pawn will be a bit too dangerous let's
say Bishop to f8 and if Queen goes back
to B3 already Queen to A3 is happening
and uh you you have to you know make
some decisions that you should not be
forced to make from a position that was
already you know quite quite good a few
moves ago so instead Knight to E2 and
now Queen to A3 offering a queen trade
but now just Bishop to C1 and once you
invites the queen trade on B3 and Magnus
accepts it it looks like Queen to A1
might be something uh but it's really
not because after Bishop captures and
pawn captures uh of course you're not
gonna capture the pawn on D5 and allow
Bishop to D3 which would win uh black
the piece uh you will instead just move
the king and now everything is fine for
example Pawn to H6 or black play
something you will capture the pawn not
completely Bishop to F5 and after Queen
back to C4 you will play Bishop D6 and
okay Black's position looks very nice
now you can't and play this because
Queen captures an E5 comes with check
but you don't have to you can just move
the queen uh and all is well Queen C7
let's say Bishop to f8 and it's a it's a
fine position white is a piece but black
has the past B Pawn which is extremely
strong due to the bishop pair uh but
again Magnus not interested in this he
doesn't want to win this game he only
needs a rock he plays Queen captures on
B3 uh Bishop captures and now Bishop to
D3
opting for further trades and vassal
trades but uh he trades the knights with
Knight to F4 so Knight captures Bishop
captures and now Pawn to C5 uh
eliminating this uh beautiful Center the
captures on C5 Bishop captures and now
vassal plays onto E6 with captures uh no
sorry first uh King to f8 was played e
captures an F7 and now Magnus goes back
after the pawn bishop to G6 with King to
F1 and now Bishop captures on F7 Bishop
captures an F7 King captures King to E2
uh and now Bishop to D4 uh we have King
to D3 attacking the bishop and here uh
Evancho played King to D3 and over the
F2 Pawn probably with the idea of
winning back the uh the the the pawn by
by capturing on B4 but there's a problem
Bishop captures an F2 Bishop to D2 and
now Bishop to C5 of course Magnus
defense uh vassal attacks with King to
C4 but now Bishop to fate uh and uh
believe it or not it was in this
position and move 43 that vassal
evenchuk resigned the game as there
seems to be nothing more to be done here
well there is a lot to play for uh he
there's no way for him to actually win
the game so I think his spirits were
just you know completely depleted and uh
he he wasn't interested in continuing
this match as uh he he needs a win and
he's not going to win this game
regardless of whether he wins back that
pawn or not now the problem is if you
capture the pawn right away then of
course the position is completely
winning for Magnus there's no question
about that for example King D6 King to
C4 and you will shield the king with
King E5 a king to D3 King to F for king
T to King to G3 King to F1 and now the
only winning move but of course not one
that would be difficult to spot for
Magnus King to H2 and now the problem is
after you play King F2 uh there is just
a very easy win King F3 Ponte H5 King F2
G4 uh not a lot to do here you either
capture or you allow up onto G3 so
captures captures and now if you go King
to F1 then 3 is winning because you take
away all of the squares from the white
king the white King has to move you're
gonna capture the pawn move the king and
queen the pawn and if you don't do this
uh for example if G3 is played instead
of moving the king then a nice King H3
and after King F1 of course now King
captures on G3 and for those of you who
are maybe new to chess um of course this
is now completely winning King to F3
King to F1 G3 King G1 G2 now you force
uh the white in the soup swung the white
King has to go to an unfavorable Square
King F2 and now G1 will uh become a
queen queen you're gonna move up the
board and this will prepare mating 2
King H3 and queen to G3 will be
checkmate now the more resilient way to
fight after Bishop to f8 is not that to
capture the pawn is to actually ignore
the pawn and play Pawn to G4 and then
you will uh yeah you will force uh
Magnus to find a very interesting ways
to win this for example if you go King
E6 then Bishop to F4 uh cuts off the
king from uh going anywhere close uh at
those pawns and then Bishop to D6 which
of course you can play because if you
trade pieces of course the position is
completely winning for Magnus he is up a
pawn uh so uh you know it's uh
definitely a possibility Bishop to E3
can be played and now you you still try
and fight but at least you uh you've
stopped the black from advancing another
thing you could do after Bishop 4 you
could play something like Pawn to G6 and
then Bishop to G3 Bishop D7 you slowly
uh approach King to D4 Bishop to F6
check King to C4 and now Bishop to E5
maybe this is how you advance and try
and reach those white pawns but now
Bishop of the H4 and if Bishop to C3 now
defending the pawn you will play Bishop
to G3 and again you have very nice
control here over the center of the
board you can even put the bishop on
effort to gain more control and it would
take Magnus quite a few moves to figure
out how to how to win this but in the
end uh probably he would he would win
this so of course Vaseline was not
interested in this not because he
doesn't think that he could maybe put up
a fight and maybe make Magnus work for
his meal but there is no way to actually
win the game and that that means that
there's just no point in him continuing
here so after Bishop to fade he resigned
and a very nice victory for Magnus
Carlsen who wins two classical games in
a row now against lastly when Chuck does
improving his raiding a little bit uh
let me just check real quickly uh what's
his current live rating uh yeah he's up
to 28.40 so very nice uh followed by
Fabiano 2784 2780 and so on and so on
and for those of you who are into
interested in how gookish versus Wang
Hao ended I will now uh tell you the
results so don't uh you know say I
spoiled it or anything you can stop the
video now uh drew the second game
against Wang Hao which means that he
also goes into the next round of
defeated World Cup uh into the
quarterfinals uh and uh well absolutely
incredible by the by the young Indian
player we'll see what uh what else he
has in store for us and all the other
games are still being played while I'm
recording this so I'm probably gonna
make another video where I'm gonna talk
about all the results of of this round
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely done by Magnus
too bad for now for Evancho who came all
this way but then okay he had to face
Magnus he didn't have a a brilliant day
you know he played the a very good chess
but very good chess you know if Magnus
is playing well is not enough to take
down Magnus Carlsen uh so yeah once
again really hope you guys enjoyed it I
would like to thank Emily London
Philip huxtenberg uh and he one check
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of defeated World Cup 2023
until it finishes thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day